a pipeline leak has spilled tens of
thousands of gallons of crude oil into a
North Dakota Creek that is two and a
half hours from Cannonball which should
ring a bell because that's where
protesters have been camped out in
opposition to the Dakota access pipeline
members of the Standing Rock Sioux and
other tribes have been fighting this
pipeline as you know we've talked about
on the grounds that it would cross
beneath the lake which provides drinking
water the Native Americans and they are
concerned that this could jeopardize the
water source and destroy what is to them
sacred land and now we have learned from
North Dakota officials that more than a
hundred and seventy six thousand gallons
of crude oil leaked from the Belle
Fourche pipeline into the ash koley
creek state environmental science
scientist bill soos says a landowner
discovered the spill on December 5th
which is about a hundred and fifty miles
from the epicenter of the Dakota access
pipeline protest camps this was
reportedly contained within hours it's
not totally clear why electronic
monitoring didn't detect the leak before
this homeowner detected the leak this is
really really embarrassing particularly
after those involved with the project
have been saying this is going to be the
safest pipeline ever we now have the
best most modern pipeline technology and
the entire pipeline world is filled with
very very depressing news because in
addition to this hundred and seventy six
thousand gallon spill that took place
just hours from where people were
protesting the pipeline on the grounds
that it was environmentally dangerous we
have learned about incoming Secretary of
Energy Rick Perry I will remind you that
Rick Perry doesn't even think the
Department of Energy should exist and
now he is going to be leading the
Department of Energy and in addition to
that we've learned that Rick Perry has
financial ties to the CEO of the Dakota
access pipeline project Kelsey Warren is
the CEO of ETP which stands for energy
transfer Partners there the company
behind the pipeline kelsey has been a
huge financial supporter of Rick Perry's
over the years uh Warren gave super pac
supporting perry's presidential campaign
six million dollars last year although
they got a refund to 4.5 million dollars
after Perry dropped out Perry is also on
the board of directors of energy
transfer Partners of course he would
have to formally leave that position
when he becomes Secretary of Energy but
nonetheless Rick Perry connected
financially to what's been going on in
the UH Dakota access pipeline world
Donald Trump connected financially to
the company as well the connections are
there every single Trump appointment so
far a total disaster for this country it
is going to get bad really really bad I
don't know how else to say it I've been
saying it for a while and with every
subsequent appointment it becomes more
and more clear big picture on energy
stepping away for a second from Trump or
Perry we should be really getting away
from pipelines period we should be going
full speed ahead in terms of alternative
energy development we've interviewed
four or five experts over the last few
years we tell us we have the technology
and we have pricing low enough that we
can make the transition off of fossil
fuels but we have to start now it's not
happening and I don't expect that to
happen under the Trump administration
Hanukkah Christmas Kwanzaa festivus
whatever you're celebrating even if it's
nothing at all even if it's just new
years you don't have to battle the
crowds to get great gift you don't have
to stand in line at the mall or the
big-box store to try to figure out what
to buy that someone won't hate instead
you can go to Barry's dot-com and choose
all sorts of berries dipped in white
chocolate milk chocolate dark chocolate
topped with chocolate chips or chopped
nuts or the decorative Swizzle they have
all sorts of unique gifts and it is more
than just berries berries dot-com has
added a number of new any number i would
say of new seasonal offerings just in
time for the end of the year holidays
and you get to choose the delivery day
and shari's berries will deliver your
gift fresh and on time guaranteed
there's only one way to get the 1999
shari's berries deal and simultaneously
help to support the david pakman show
you go to Barry's dot-com berr IES
dot-com you click on the microphone in
the top right
of the page and enter my code Pakman
that's PA que ma n something for
everyone at shari's berries and
importantly something for every taste
berries dot-com you click on the
microphone and you type in pakman